what have you enjoyed most about the
lost season of once upon a time well you
know getting to do this arc as Ursula is
you know it's just been unbelievable to
work with Victoria Smurfette and Kristin
Bauer I mean the whole group has been
everybody at once upon a time it's a
really amazing team and they work hard
they make like a movie in ten days you
know but particularly cuz I got to work
with these girls so closely they're so
brave and funny and smart and you know
we just had it was like the you know
supernatural Charlie's Angels we just
had a ball there's nothing like it's
like getting to go in there and just
like just cause havoc you know but look
you know when we started we were all
really tentative because these are
iconic you know
creatures characters and you know you
don't want to mess it up you know and I
know that Kristin didn't watch
Maleficent and you know Vic just kept
looking to the cartoon and you know I I
I was trying to match the you know the
the voice you know because obviously I'm
not like you know overweight and purple
like you know you know and with
tentacles you know but um you know just
trying to find out like what what it is
about me that I can bring to this to
make it like my own and we had a
wonderful director Jon Amiel who's also
British and he really helped us set the
tone to find these find these gals and
let you know Vic and I got to do a lot
of stuff together which was amazing and
we sort of found our own little like you
know vibrational Starsky and Hutch kinda
like you know back and forth which I
think the fans really responded to can I
ask what attracted you to this one that
you saw and oh I have to do this well
they called and asked so that's always
the you know first thing it's like what
but like the idea of me really you want
me for this it's like the most exciting
thing to be a part of something that's
this you know a to be asked to do such
an iconic character but also to be a
part of this incredible world that is
once upon a time you know it's such a
it's so well crafted it's so well
thought out and it's just a lot of fun
so you jump at that chance you say yes
please win how soon can I get there what
do you need and what can I do and can i
you know color my hair blonde and like
what you know what do you need for me so
you know that is you know I I'm
not at that point at which that I get to
let go oh it's role in the world do I
want to do like I don't have that like
luxury you know but um when somebody
calls NASA to do something this you you
know thank your lucky stars
so no doubts then no doubts about like
wanting to do it there's doubt in like
what am i doing you know how do I do it
not not can I do it how do I do it and
in fact the first episode that we did do
we shot a scene or a couple scenes in
the in this episode that was the winter
finale break with a director named Ralph
Hammacher who's lovely but you know they
were already in the middle of doing all
this stuff and like we were flown in to
like just start in this big you know
scene so there wasn't a lot of time to
like sort of like figure out what was
happening so you know first like we come
in and I'm throw this tent first of all
I had to learn how to throw tentacles
from you know my pelvis you know which
aren't there and that our CGI and and
you know get bail around that you know
around the neck and I kept wanted to use
my hands you know cuz when you fight you
want to like put your dukes up in there
put your hands down those aren't your
tentacles and I think right right right
like you know it's like if you literally
watch that first thing there's like like
I'm like fighting pulling my hands up so
it's how to do it you know and then once
you got in the groove of figure out like
you know how to throw a tentacle you
know if you know as you do you know
wanna you know I mean obviously Disney's
full of iconic heroes but I think for
most people Ursula remains the most
scary villain the one that kind of
resonates you have early memories of
watching the cartoon kind of that
affecting you in any way um well I think
I was um a little older than a kid when
that movie came out but um so I didn't
scare me as much as I think it like when
I first watched it with my daughter she
was terrified like we we couldn't get
past like we had to stop at that and
turn it off and then like slowly we've
gotten you know back to it and and then
my little one won't even go on the ride
at Disneyland like that's it like forget
it
Ursula like terrifies her but yeah I
didn't really think that I didn't I
didn't realize how scary but I think
because she's this she's really a
monster you know and one of the things
that they was in once upon a time that
like evil isn't
it's made and which I loved about my
whole backstory on the none of you guys
have gotten it here yet but um you know
how I became you know but I choose like
I chose to be a monster a monster not
just this you know like Victoria is
still a woman you know there's still a
person in there I think she the way they
told the story is actually she's much
scarier than I am but um you know to be
a creature is is really I think that's
what makes her so scarier that she's
she's a beast and and so fierce and not
afraid to like just kill and I think
that you don't see that so readily the
other villains are more wicked and
manipulative and they cast spells
you know Minds just like I'll get ya and
I think that's what's so scary is that
I'll just get you I mean you said that
me never see your kids are scared of us
laughs how do they feel about the fact
that yeah well it took a minute my older
one is um you know I would I would
FaceTime I'd call them on the you know
computer and if I was in character you
know I didn't have the tentacles because
those are CGI but if I had you know just
in the makeup because the makeup is so
incredible and the hair and the you know
and the little one would just be like
that's still you right you're still in
there and I said yeah it's still mommy
it's just mommy you know but so mifune's
thing was the little one would love love
to watch it and the older one was like
I'm good go do anything but watch this
right now because it's just too much
well sadly Ursula got her happy ending
you know sorry to spoiler ah I got my
voice back so um but the good news a bit
about you know once upon a time is that
nobody dies you know and nobody stays
happy for too long so hopefully I'll be
able to resurface in that world you know
I just would like to be utilized as a
way that like when they need something
you know handled like look she's like
the fixer you know she's the town fixer
you know whether it's like for good or
for ill you know you call on her for you
know I think that would be kind of fun
to just be of
this took gold or the I beg your pardon
well you know they were so busy wrapping
up the end of the season like they
haven't yet figured out what the
storyline is next for the next year but
like I said you know they brought Zelena
back you know from Oz and you just never
know I think tentacled my creature
because then you can do more things you
know like mermaids mermaid you know
times and it's pretty and whatever but
like you know that you know my tentacle
beast can she can take care of stuff she
can reach things she can slap people
it's good wasn't what that's go thanks
whitter Instagram how different
different characters and what's a good
time would be if they had access to
social media wow that's a good one you
know I think that the villains that the
villains would run it you know because
they you know they'd be able to like
kulli a you know a nice audience of you
know supporters because everybody likes
a bad guy you know I think the heroes
would be too busy battling like you know
for good to get there their way to make
it to spend time on social media you
know unless they're like we lost him
again we can't find Henry I call out the
armed guards I don't she didn't like
that at all you know but those are her
babies we had a whole like some of it
got cut but in the first episode where I
worked with John and the director and
you know he was like this year those are
children you know like all those I love
how they set that whole you know space
up that was just a teaser my children I
get to be with him so as much as like
she didn't like shoveling you know fish
shits and all that sort of thing she
still got to be with her people you know
you know it just made sense with the
ties the Disney if you've got a
particular favorite Disney film I love
the Pixar I love all the Disney Pixar
films in particular the Toy Story series
it's just I mean I wept like a baby at
that last you know movie I was holding
hands with my sister and they're like
holding hands like going that
and she's like 45 you know because we
kind of grew up with that you know to
watch that whole journey like those are
they're just I mean Disney knows how to
pull the heartstrings something those
are especially wonderful when obviously
you mentioned earlier on that there's a
there's a physicality to Ursula but also
the vocal performance particularly the
original cartoon is so iconic you talked
a little bit about how he found that
aspect of the character well you know I
think that for me that was my you know
you got to find your way in you know I
always say like when I go in for a part
and that's the thing like that's good
and bad about being offered something is
that like you you're so unsettling with
that mask on it's freaking me out you
know when you when you go in to audition
for something at least for me I have to
find well if I'm if I know what that
character wears I know I feel really
great about when I walk in you know I
mean like some things when you go in to
play like you know a detective work you
know like it's very plain it's very
simple but there is sort of like
everyone has their uniform whether it's
a mom or you know it's like what kind of
mom and like what kind of cop you know
is it a beat cop is it detect it like
there is a way to walk in what shoes are
you wearing and what do you you know how
like for me that's my way and it's like
putting on some sort of costume and
mm-hmm with Ursula because you know it
was you know I was asked to do it I
didn't know what you know and though
it's like what are you what do you bring
to this how do you you know and the
voice was the best way because I do have
a low voice and I do have sort of that
you know ki can match that cadence you
know that the voice actress whose name
escapes in right now but she's so
incredible you know it's just this
that's what you can bring that's what I
could bring know the particular lines
that you really love saying in that
voice
God you know it's so funny my my
daughter in the preschool like all her
friends were saying to Ursula like they
want to come up with like say you
something you know but yes there was a
particular line in the episode of my
backstory where hook and I are trying to
get my get the seashell
to work to bring my voice back and and I
said I said I don't even know if I can
match it in the voice but I said don't
mess with a woman with a tart
don't don't try and take on a woman with
eight arms especially when you only have
one you know and it's just like [ __ ]
slap seven so you just feel like such a
tough guy you know it's always great to
get like those great lines I mean
talking about tough characters do you
think that one of the secrets of the
show success is that so many of the
strong characters the most interesting
characters tend to do the girls Wow um
well that you know is you know I think
that will you look at Disney all that
all the interesting characters are women
you know and for the most part in those
you know Disney stories and and the
fairy tales you know it's that they're
the protagonists and then they're the
they're the protagonists and they're
also the villains so you're are you
given that surface you know but we're
lucky on once one time you know the
writers are so you know Robert and I
mean I'm sorry it was like I was like I
was thinking about something else um
they they have created these beautiful
women and these beautiful characters
that are so fun to watch and then you've
got Lana and Ginny and you know Jennifer
there who bring to life these you know
and who they fill it you know but I but
people love the villains the most they
love Robert they love who was not a
woman but they loved Robert they loved I
mean Lana they people like flip out you
know if you say anything about Lana
Parrilla like they just leave fall apart
because she's just this majestic
creature you know and it's in in life
and in you know art she is that but I
was happy to be a part of that we say
there was bringing lots of new great
characters into the show he read he
loved to see brought into that world
moving forward Wow I mean there's you
know I feel like they've literally you
know mind that you know well deep so I
you're asking a very jet-lagged lady a
very I don't have to think about who you
know but like you know I
I was surprised they were able to bring
Ursula in there you know like in the way
that they did it's it's it's you know I
just feel lucky
you